our draft now and i i will admit i
screwed up earlier it's not the most
important matchups for division around
weekend it's the most important
non-quarterback so chris you've got the
trivia question and we'll see if i get
the first pick okay here we go so
nine of the last 12 participants in the
super bowl have been number one seeds
all right nine of the last 12 have been
number one seeds there were three
teams that weren't they were all number
two seeds can you name
two of the three two seeds
that have made it to the super bowl over
the last six years
you can do this come on
three two seeds have made it to the
super bowl over the last how many years
six years the last 12 participants
yes
okay
uh
it would have been better if i'd have
been listening to the question from the
start the last nine of the last 12
participants in the super bowl has been
number one seeds right okay okay
the other three were two seeds
i would be horrible on jeopardy i was
watching that last night yeah
all right just let's sound the wrong
just make them make them tell me who
they are
both teams were number two seeds right
the rams and the patriots
so those were two right there and then
the falcons in 2016 were a two seed who
ended up hosting green bay don't act
like you know you have it in front of
you i knew i was all over it
all right yeah i i wasn't here's the
problem i wasn't listening to shocker
and that screwed me up from the get-go i
thought you were talking about nine of
the last 12 years not none of the last
12 participants yeah well listen next
time stop stop texting mds or darren gan
or somebody and just do the damn show
and listen to me okay make make the pick
you get derek henry go nope i'm not
gonna go with derek henry i'm gonna go
somebody from that that team though i'm
gonna go with arthur smith all right the
offensive coordinator the tennessee
titans
one well
this is why first off hey tennessee
titans it's a good defense i don't think
they're gonna stop baltimore on the
offensive side of the ball so tennessee
you're gonna have to score more than 14
points on the offensive side of the ball
to win this game this week and that's
where i look at arthur smith and i go
arthur smith i just hey
i don't think derek henry henry's going
to be able to run roughshod all over the
baltimore ravens defense like he did
against the new england patriots last
week baltimore's got a lot of big run
stoppers they're they're very good at
playing run defense in general and where
i go to arthur smith is it's on him to
find some more creative ways in the
passing game if they want any chance to
win this game in baltimore baltimore
secondary is really good it's almost
every bit as good as new england's that
we saw last week and mike when i watched
that film like the new england dbs were
running the routes for the tennessee
titans wide receivers like they knew the
coach had told them when they lined up
in this formation they're gonna run
these routes and they were running the
routes before the tennessee titan wide
receivers they better change some things
up find some more creative ways to get
the ball to these guys this week because
they're not going to be able to depend
on derrick henry running for 180
something yards against this ravens
defense would be shocked they're gonna
have to do and be a little more
effective in the pass game
see now i feel bad taking derek henry
because i think that's the more sensible
selection because derek henry is the
most important non-quarterback because
if he does run roughshod over the ravens
defense it does make all the difference
in the world it doesn't matter what ryan
tannehill does it doesn't matter what
arthur smith does it doesn't matter what
anybody does if derek henry can get it
done so i'm going to say you picked the
wrong guy and i'm going to say
exactly
they barely won the game last week
against a lesser team and he ran all
over them so that was my point he needs
to do it again he needs to do it again
he needs to do more he needs to be the
guy that he was last week for the titans
to have a chance because what he can do
and if the ravens are smart the titans
are smart and this is where i'm gonna
i'm gonna uh come dangerously close to
agreeing with you
the broader strategy is bleed the clock
and shorten the game and give the ravens
fewer opportunities so they feel a
greater sense of urgency
maybe you do get a lucky uh sucker punch
you catch them with early on and it it
makes them uh think uh this may not be
our day but keep their offense off the
field yeah but i think derek henry's
ability to run like he did on saturday
night against the patriots is gonna be a
big part of that so i am going with
derrick that's all right that's all good
that's a good pick it just wasn't as
good as mine so round one to me here we
go to round two
um
i'm going to will fuller i just you know
i feel like we talk about him every week
the last six or seven weeks but i mean i
i gotta talk about him again
you know again the texans aren't gonna
come out with a victory if their offense
plays the way it did last week against
the buffalo bills that's not gonna
happen you know this is a different
squad they're in kansas city i think we
can sit here and go oh if you give the
opportunities to patrick mahomes in
kansas city you know they're going to
come away with more 16 than 16 points
than what buffalo did last week i mean
if the texans play the way they did in
the first three quarters this week
against kansas city then they might be
down 28 to 7 going into the fourth
quarter and that might just be night
night they need will fuller to be big
time on the offensive side of the ball
spagnolo as you and i have talked about
a lot has really done a great job with
this kansas city defense they like a
bill belichick will take away your
number one option i would think there's
gonna be times where they're gonna
double de'andre hopkins on big big plays
and say beat us with somebody else and
it's gonna come down to will fuller will
fuller he doesn't even necessarily just
have to have a big day he's just got to
be out there be close to 100
and be able to really run his his just
presence on the field will open things
up for the texans offense and kenny
stills and fells and deandre hopkins so
i think he's very important if the
texans want to pull off some sort of
upset in kansas city this week
good call by you he was on my list i
don't know that i would have taken him
this early but you're right he has to
play and he has to be available to
spread out the kansas city chiefs
defense and make it easier for deandre
hopkins and kenny stills to get things
done and maybe will fuller pops a big
gain and makes the difference uh at a
key moment and maybe the texans have a
better chance to win i'm gonna go with
aaron jones the packers running back and
when we were watching the packers in the
lions week 17 there was a point in the
first half where aaron jones went down
awkwardly it
looked like he'd messed up his arm
remember that chris yeah and our
reaction was they're done if aaron jones
is injured they've got no chance right
to do anything in the post season and
even though it's all about oh aaron
rodgers and his legacy and trying to get
a second super bowl that's fine aaron
jones has been a key member of that team
this year aaron rodgers has supported
jones for mvp consideration they need a
big day from jones to allow
the run game to complement the pass game
and the packers to ultimately outscore
the seattle seahawks yeah no i mean he
was on my list too and i thought about
just taking him as well you know i was
almost split between taking him or
devonte adams because you know i mean
mike all your points are very real i
just think of seattle old school pete
carroll like he's one of those coaches
that's like all right we're going to
take away the run he still kind of has
that old school mentality about him
right to where i think they're going to
focus a lot on aaron jones and like i
almost picked devonta adams just to go
like i think this could be a game rogers
just goes hey it's one on one me and him
are better than that guy covering him
and we're just gonna work it to death
we'll be interesting to see how they how
that plays out um
you know i think i don't know what i
want to do here i want to go with i'm
going to go with the two defense ends in
minnesota you know can i pick the duo or
do you have to pick one
i'm going to pick the duo screw mike
floria okay the hell with him i'm going
to danielle hunt
i didn't
you keep wanting to call him daniel it's
denial ah denial i'm sorry my wife is
danielle and i struggle with the english
language and it's not personal okay i'm
sorry about that danielle i really am
danielle just don't call your wife to
neil hey you sure she'll get the wrong
ideas right right but i do think hunter
and everson griffin are going to play a
huge part of this game one they got to
be phenomenal against the run the 49ers
are phenomenal about running the ball on
the edges of defenses right where the
defensive ends are so they'll be
important in stopping that aspect you
know they'll be important in stopping
like the speed sweeps and the reverses
that the 49ers run you know will they be
patient or disciplined on the back side
and the biggest thing mike as we always
talk about when you're playing a really
good offense
man when you can just get to the
quarterback with your front four
and keep seven guys back in coverage and
mike zimmer i'm sure he wants that this
week with shanahan and all the pre-snap
movement and play-action passes and
people going a million different ways he
wants to use that combination of seven
and coverage as effectively as possible
and that's why it'll be very important
for number 97 and 99 to have huge days
and see if they can win the battle
between them and mcglinchey and joe
staley and the vikings had some wrinkles
defensively for the saints last weekend
i think that zimmer has some other
things up his sleeve for this week
against the 49ers all right i was
thinking about going george kittle
uh because i think that that his
presence will help make it easier for
jimmy garoppolo in his first playoff
game and kittle's got that that vibe to
him he's got that pro wrestler thing
he's he just he's a great character and
i feel like this is the kind of stage
that he is destined to show up on in a
big way so i guess he's not as important
because i assume he's going to have a
big game right
it's not as uncertain it is more
uncertain when it comes to davey and
clowney the master of the f up the play
the guy who had that huge game against
the 49ers and came back and had a pretty
good game against the eagles in the wild
card round
controversial hit on carson wentz the uh
the green bay packers had better know
where jadavian clowney is anytime he's
on the field because he won't just f up
the play he may have up your quarterback
as well and the packers will not survive
if for the second straight week the
seahawks send the starting quarterback
to the sidelines because this time it
won't be josh mccown it'll be tim boyle
taking over for aaron rodgers which
means at that point you should just turn
your tv to something else because we
know what's going to happen if tim boyle
plays quarterback for the pack pretty
much you're right i mean it's a good i
you know i wanted to picture debbie
unconnie the only reason i didn't do it
is because you took aaron jones and i
figured i'd change up the game a little
bit but i'm i'm with you i'm totally
with you and you're right i mean that
game became inevitable even though like
philadelphia hung around i mean at no
point did i really think josh mccown was
going to deliver there without playing
all year in that moment
against seattle i mean i just didn't so
that would be a huge ball but you're
right man gideon clowney you just know
when he's on the field it's a different
defense when he's just somewhat close to
100 percent he the stats just don't say
it all with clowney he ruins plays and
his presence out there on the field and
physicality and size and everything
really helps out that seattle seahawks
defense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports